let's go to ashley in oklahoma city yeah
i
would like help um deciding on if i
should send my
six-year-old to public school or just
homeschool her
okay tell me about it what's going on
what are you thinking
um whenever i was pregnant
all of that i i was dead set on
homeschooling
and then i realized that i'm not very
social myself
when you met your kid and you were like
nope yes
so i can do all of the academic stuff
all of that but i
i'm not very good at letting her play
with other kids or
meeting moms to play with other kids how
come and i guess i
uh i get i just don't do it myself
oh okay you don't like other people i
mean i do
but i have a younger daughter and i
don't like having to
wrestle both of them um
but yeah i now i'm thinking about
public school and i feel like it would
be a better option i'm just still
nervous about that
what are you nervous about um
she's very i don't want her to
her innocence to go away and her to be
exposed to
things that she wouldn't be if she were
at home
okay and just the pressure that school
will bring
i wanted to stay young as as long as
possible i guess
gotcha so what do you
think is going to happen in a public
school like what type of exposure are
you worried about or what type of
pressure
are you worried about because you're
talking about like kindergarten at this
point right
yes so in between learning how to count
and read what type of
what type of pressure are you thinking
of
uh well my mind automatically goes to
bad things but
tell me what the bad things are learn
about sex and learn about body parts and
learn swear words
and learn like watch somebody get
punched like what are the things that
you're worried about
no more of my niece she was exposed to
pornography at seven
um from school that and
her just worrying about what other
people think um
not having that confidence in herself or
starting to be insecure
okay all of that which i don't know if
it happens at kindergarten or not but
i mean it happens everywhere here here's
here's my thought on it okay um we went
through this same
scenario here in my house um i'm a big
big big believer in public schools love
them love them
love them and over the last five to ten
years
i hate with all of my guts
this paranoid obsession
with technology in schools
if we don't get them this chromebook
this device this thing this ipad then
they're going to be so far behind and
they're going to fall apart and the
world's going to be and schools across
the country
are spending billions of dollars on on
like gadgets for kids it's not learning
right
um and i know there's some tech ed folks
some ed tech folks who want to
go to fight me on it that's fine i'd
love to i'd love to meet
up with you on it that's a different
phone call um but i'm a big believer in
public schools the teachers
many teachers are are extraordinarily
underselling them they're magic
what they do and they get up every day
thinking about our kids there are crappy
teachers out there no question about
that
here's here's my thought on it your kid
over time is going to be exposed to
is going to hear bad words he's going to
learn wild things about sex that are so
like are anatomically impossible but
that's how they're gonna figure it out
right
they're gonna learn weird things about
how people
do christmas differently and why does
your mom look like that
and why does your dad have like they're
gonna learn those things
where i landed personally in our home
is i want them to have those experiences
and those
questions in my house i want
to cultivate a spirit or an ethos of
communication on our house
i want to um like cultivate hey
tell me about something you saw that
you'd never seen before i asked my son
the other day i was like hey what new
words have you learned this year and he
told me the words he learned this year
and i was like what do those even mean
i never had that conversation with my
dad but i wanted to teach him a few
things number one i'm not scared of any
question you're gonna bring me
none zero number two those words coming
out of your mouth lightning doesn't
strike you you don't die
number three they actually have meanings
number four what's the context why would
we say that why wouldn't we say that
right so i want them to
him to be a consumer of the world around
him and
i want to be a safe resource for him and
so
sometimes people take that logic to an
extreme and they say well i want my kids
to get wasted with all their friends at
my house because i want them to you know
i mean and there's a point where
that gets stupid right the roi and that
gets dumb
um but that's why i am that's why i have
no problem with the public school system
that i happen to be a part of
i do know there's some really rough
public schools out there that aren't any
good so you as
a parent are gonna have to be discerning
about that um i'll tell you on our end
we went and my wife especially went met
with the teacher met with the counselor
met with everybody when we moved
what's this experience gonna be like and
it was remarkable and we've also been
really loud about
here's what we will accept with
technology what we won't accept with
technology
and so some of that's just being a an
involved and engaged parent
not an idiotic parent but an engaged
parent um
how much of this and let me ask you this
because i've experienced some own house
how much of this do you have guilt
that you wanted to be a homeschooler and
it's not working out for you and your
child
um i think that's most of it i feel like
i
should be able to do that um because i'm
her mom
ah there you go i experienced that my
wife experienced that many of our
friends experienced that especially when
kova kicked off
that we were gonna stay at home we're
gonna homeschool this is gonna be great
and then
two months in it's like i just had this
image of showing up to my front porch
and my wife's on the front porch just
smoking a cigarette holding the shovel
and i would just know like what
one of my kids is in the yard right um
it just wasn't going to end well
and then there's all of that compound
and guilt like oh i can't even
be around my own kid i can't right and
all that stuff's unnecessary but it just
piles up on you
um why why why
is that seed sitting there in your soul
why is that is that seed taking root
in your heart there um
i'm not really sure i that's kind of how
i feel about a lot of things i just
always put it on
myself
why do you do that to yourself i don't
i don't know so i want to
like i should be able to do all the
things and do them well
so do me a favor tonight okay um
your husband a good guy yes okay
so i want y'all to do a uh
uh an exercise together okay
i want you to sit with him and to write
down
all of the things that you quote unquote
should be able to do
and which is just a should list you
should be able to
change all the diapers with a smile on
your face and joy in your heart because
this is your precious baby
you should be able to wash all the skin
marks out of a six-year-old's
underwear because i just love that baby
right
um you should be able to never get
annoyed with
mommy hey mom hey mom hey mom right i
want you to write down all of those
shoulds
and then i want you and your husband to
go through those and demand
evidence from them like is this true and
my guess is
a whole bunch of those shoulds have been
put there by
your parents your in-laws your
your interpretation of um
what instagram nonsense like this
curated existence that's not real but
that we
especially moms beat each other up with
right all you're going to find a lot of
this is just garbage
because my guess is ashley you're a
great great mom
and you love your kid a lot and
you ran into a situation where there's
going to be a professional that's going
to be better
at a particular role and that's awesome
great send your kid to public school
cultivate a conversation that happens
every day
let your teacher know of your kid hey my
seven-year-old
niece or nephew got a news to
pornography that cannot happen with my
child
and it's your responsibility as the
teacher who gave them this tech
to keep that from happening and i'd
rather you see a bulldog
be a bulldog on behalf of your kid then
beat yourself up for not being all
things to all people does that make
sense
yeah i want you to be a mom that
delights in the things that she does
well
and is bold and brave enough to pass
along the things that she doesn't do
well
and i don't want your child to ever feel
that mom
tension that angst that anxiety because
a kid is gonna backfill that as though
it's her fault and she's gonna try to
solve it
yes i see that now sometimes tell me
about that
um well she's the oldest of the two and
she's just one
she just like me perfectionist just
wants to do everything and she's always
saying i'm trying to do the right thing
so i don't get in trouble
and again she's she's five right now so
so is that how you are in
in other aspects of your life
yeah since i was a kid i was the same
way
who were you protecting at your house my
little sister
who were you trying to please um
i was trying to be noticed by my parents
my mom and dad
okay my dad wasn't really around so i
always thought it had to
be something for him to be around gotcha
you're going to be extra sparkly and
extra shiny right
yeah is that exhausting yeah
okay so here's what i want you to do i
want you
to stop the performance with your
husband
and stop the performance with your
little baby with your six-year-old
with your new child and i want you to
begin
practicing just being you
and i want you to practice loving and
connecting with that kid
come hell or high water and that starts
with you've heard me say this over and
over it starts with those little bitty
knucklehead things like
every day in the morning and every day
in the evening i'm gonna hold my kid's
face and i'm gonna look them in the eyes
and let's say i love you
and i'm so so so glad that i get to
be your mom and dad i get to be your mom
i got picked to be your mom
and they'll go ma ma and when they bring
you that paper and say look
the teacher put a check mark on it isn't
this so good
your response is not yeah that's right
or why don't you get a check plus the
response is
did you work really hard are you proud
of the work that you put into that
and they say yeah i'm proud and say i'm
really proud that you're proud
good for you because we want to praise
their efficacy inside not the
achievement right
and you sound like you're ready to rock
and roll send your kid to public school
be really clear with your husband about
what y'all want
at a public school what you won't
tolerate at public school and be direct
with it
and then if you do it for a year and
it's no good then you can get some more
skills
when it comes back to considering
homeschooling again
we've got close friends who've
homeschooled and they love
it they're incredible at it and we've
got friends who've tried it we tried it
didn't work
didn't work for us and our kids are
absolutely thriving in
the schools that they're at so it's an
individual thing for every family
don't do it because you're scared of my
kid's gonna hear a thing or see a thing
i actually want that especially when
they're in my home i don't want them the
first time they hear something they've
never heard before
to be at a college when they live seven
hours away from me i don't want them the
first time they see something that
scares them
to be eight hours away to college or 17
hours away at a new job
i don't want that i want them to have
those experiences when they're with me
so we can create that conversation
i love your heart ashley good for you
you've got this you've got this
don't doubt yourself honor yourself and
do the should exercise tonight
with your husband i his eyes are going
to bug out of his head
when he sees the things all written out
that you think you should be doing
as a mom as a wife as just a neighbor
um and hopefully you can have some peace
when you mark those things off me like i
shouldn't do that nobody should like
cleaning skid marks it's disgusting
it's awful